everybody says Gary Vaynerchuk and I
have the yes virus
what is the yes virus the yes virus and
I think a ton of you have this at least
the good peeps is when you want to say
yes to everything when you feel like you
can do everything and what most of all
you don't want to let people down or you
just want to try to check off a lot of
boxes or accomplish a lot of things you
know maybe you want to call it big eyes
you know you feel like you can consume
all that chocolate cake
I very much for most of my career have
had the yes virus and I want to make
this video to kind of leave people from
their yes virus because the problem with
the s virus and why I call it a virus is
when you were trying to say yes to
everything you end up doing nothing and
recently in the last six months nine
months I've been trying to say no more
often and it becomes so unnatural for me
you know saying no breaks my heart you
know I have a lot of energy clearly and
and I feel like I can do a lot of things
and it feels selfish to say no but what
I'm realizing as I'm getting older is
the gray hairs start coming in I've been
able to accomplish a lot more this last
year by giving myself a little bit of a
vaccine to the s virus by saying no more
often first of all the big eye-opener to
me is how many people actually respect
you saying no instead of just deleting
that email or avoiding it coming up
front and saying hey listen I've got you
know vaynermedia to build 120 employees
were at 25 I would have never been able
to get to this place in the last year if
I kept saying yes to everything and
every interview request and help every
single person build their business while
neglecting mine and as a giver and as
somebody who gets much more satisfaction
out of helping others than myself it's
very hard to say no it's actually not as
fun to say no I don't like this selfish
rewards that come along with saying no
but if you're trying to accomplish
something
if you're trying to execute and I've got
to tell you in a world of like everybody
starting a business and everybody's not
rapport now and everybody can raises
money I've never been more attracted to
execution a little Bret Hart the
excellent execution is what I'm looking
for I'm looking for Bret Hart's and to
be a Bret Hart and to execute I've had
to say a whole lot of knows lately and
and it's been very rewarding I'm very
thankful for the way people respect the
know and so if you have the S virus I'm
really not sure what the vaccine was I
don't know what the turning point was
for me in late summer last year but if
you're able to somehow break through
maybe we can make tomorrow no day if you
can just say no to two or three things
tomorrow respectfully and see how that
feels I think you'll be stunned on how
much more you could accomplish in the
things that you're trying to accomplish
over the next 300 plus days